hello everyone and welcome to an
absolute Thriller from this year's uh
chess Olympiad that is currently being
played it is uh pragyananda versus Java
kirsinder of it is India 2 versus
Uzbekistan and it is the match that
everyone's absolutely been waiting for
uh so I thought that uh we're gonna be
showing the the game from board one
first is that's the one that everyone is
expecting the most where gookish is
playing against Abdul satrov but this
game uh is not only incredible but it
also will have great effect on what
happens in that game but we're gonna
we're gonna discuss this a bit more
after we check out the actual game so
let's dive straight into it Prague has
the white pieces and he opens with D4 a
cinder of replies with Knight to F6 we
have C4 G6 at night to C3 and Bishop to
G7 and yes I have improved the quality
of the audio but
um you know it was a it was such a silly
mistake that the the quality was bad
that I am even ashamed to talk about it
so so let's just continue we have Pawn
to E4 we have D6 Knight to F3 and here
Castle this is all very standard stuff
Kings Indian defense the absolute Main
Line Bishop to E2 and pawn to E5 pretty
much played exclusively here we have
castles and now uh we have a move that
is extremely rare here uh you usually
play with the Knight Knight the C6 is
the most common idea on it E6 um the
second most common Knight the D7 third
most common uh but H6 has been played
only a handful of times and also in a
match between an Indian player and
against an uh Uzbek player here uh the
game has this position has been reaching
again between gookish and Northern
2021 Video Grand Swiss where yakubov won
with this H6 idea against the gookish so
uh Prague will have his hands full with
this one Rook to E1 Knight B to D7 and
now in the game that we've mentioned
gookish versus Jacob with uh Bishop to
F1 was played but here we have Queen to
C2 by prago and it is now as of move
nine that we have a completely new game
so let's see how the game continues
Cinderella replies with Rook to E8 uh
the cap first and e5d captors and the
bishop to E3 just nicely continuing
development we have Pawn to C6 now
countering the uh the Knight on C3 and
now we have Knight the A4 by playing C6
you have also weakened B6 uh to some
extent and now uh Prague wants to play
C5 and grab full control over D squares
so Queen to C7 and pawn to C5 we have B5
chasing away the Knight but now C
captures on B6 a captures and B6 and now
Pawn to H3 taking away the G4 Square
from Black's pieces
uh we have Queen the B8 now preparing B5
and Rook e to D1 uh just grabbing hold
of the D file we have Pawn to B5 Knight
to C5 and now we have a trade Knight
captures Bishop captures and the bishop
again comes the B uh comes the E6 with
Bishop to D6 attacking the queen and now
Queen to B6 so uh what do you do here uh
black is attacking the A2 Pawn so you
could try and defend this but you could
also just capture the E5 Pawn progress
says of course we're gonna capture the
E5 Pawn we have Rook captures I need to
Rook captures and now Bishop captures an
A2 and now uh the position is really a
complicated one but there is a move that
Prague can play uh well sort of almost
grabbed the winning Advantage right
right from the start it's hard to say if
it's actually winning or do you have to
play like a perfect game to win it but
uh if you find it you will have chances
to win the game so feel free to pause
the video game the video and try to find
the the only move that grants you such
Advantage for Prague while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that you
can trap the bishop on A2 and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Bishop captures on F6 this is very
important as we eliminate a very strong
attacker that is attacking the the pawn
here and also uh the bishop on F6 will
give us a valuable tempo for pushing the
spawn to E5 in some variations so Bishop
captures an F6 and up onto B3 just
threatening to win the bishop here and
okay if the bishop is defended you can't
really play Rook day one because the
bishop covers that square but now we
already said if the Rook joins the
defense then E5 can be played and then
you no longer control the A1 Square so
there are many options here for example
if Rook to A8 uh or black is just lost
we just play E5 Bishop to A7 now Rook to
A1 the bishop will fall and if Queen to
A5 defending now we just play Queen
captures on C6 and now the B5 Pawn is
hanging as well and the black's position
is just terrible so here uh cinderov
plays the queen to A5 right away it is
the absolute best way to defend but now
not to Rook to a one first Prague who
plays Queen captures on C6 there's
always time to uh further attack the
bishop because now The Rook is hanging
so this is grabbing a pawn with Tempo
Rook to E6 attacks the queen and now
Queen to C8 with check King G7 Queen
back to C2 now preparing Rook to A1 and
the queen to A3 saying okay we attack my
Bishop I'm just gonna capture this Pawn
on B3 so E5 now absolute strongest by
Prague and Bishop captures Knight
captures Rook captures and then now
comes Queen to C3 just pinning that Rook
on E5 and how do you how do you continue
this the problem is if you play
something like F6 which of course is
possible there's the very nice Bishop
captures on B5 and now how are you
defending the it's just impossible if
Queen captures on B3 you can just go
Rook D7 check and if King to f8 okay you
don't have this because the Rook can
just block with Rook here but you can
play Queen C7 and that's it this is an
idea this is an idea I mean so many
ideas here it will be impossible to
defend this black will get checkmated so
instead after this uh Queen to see it
three move we have a queen to C5 and
this is again absolute strongest move by
cinderov uh offering a queen trade but
also preventing Pawn to F4 if you can
get a four in then that's game over so
how do you how do you continue this uh
probably just keeps the tension Queen to
B2 uh he's still now at some point he
hopes to get the
Kinga away from the G1 square and push
this set for pawn bishop captures on B3
seemingly offering a bishop but if Queen
captures then Rook captures an E2 and
this is good for cinderov so Rook to E1
the only way to seize Advantage with
white is such a brilliant move uh it
seems it seems weird since the bishop is
an E2 but it works wonders here for
Prague thus shot back to E6 and now
Bishop to G4 and now you have to play
something as The Rook here is hanging so
King the F6 uh sorry about that King to
F6 only way to play this now King to H2
finally on pinning and of course the
queen now cannot capture because Queen
captures an E5 and now F4 is coming so
G5 stopping this and now G3 going for F4
and now F4 is Unstoppable so cinderov
has to accept just going into a worse
end game against Prague he goes for
Bishop characters and G4 he has to allow
F4 Ponte F4 and now Bishop back to F5 we
have Rook captures and E5 threatening
all sorts of nasty discoveries but
luckily there is Queen to C2 with Czech
and now Prague just happily trades down
Queen captures on C2 if you're wondering
about the weird Discovery with the Rook
T2 check it's not as great because here
we just trade attacked opponent B5 and
Bishop D7 defends the pawn with uh the
move problem Place uh he easily wins the
pawn just Queen captures and C2 Bishop
captures and The Rook captures on B5 and
now we have this end game that is uh
winning for white probably with perfect
play but it's a very very hard to play
it and you can't just force a win here
you have to play Perfect moves and you
have to hope that your opponent does not
play Perfect move so King to G6 Rook the
B for now and pawn to F6 just keeping
everything solid pawns and dark squares
Bishop is a light Square Bishop King to
G2 prago starts bringing the king into
the game and now Bishop to D3 King F2 uh
Bishop to A6 now your Cinderella has to
wait and see what the progo will do uh
onto G4 hoping to get F5 in but now of
course G captures an F4 we have root
captures and F4 and pawn to H5 now uh
trying to trade off as many pawns as
possible but this might not be the
absolute cleanest way to play this for
black but it's it's such a complicated
end game that any move you make can
probably be bested and also uh you know
even if you play like a bad movie it
could also be a really good one it's a
weird thing to say but you know it is as
it is so G captures an H5 with check
King captures Rook captures and F6 and
we get this position a rook King and
pawn against the king and Bishop like I
said with perfect play it is winning but
it's very very hard to win it so Bishop
to D3 and now comes King to G3 the real
problem is uh kicking away the king from
uh from d square so once you finally
kick away the king all the way it will
be very hard for the white king to gain
control over these squares to actually
push the pawn over the threshold but
you'll see what I mean invited with
Bishop to G6 Rook to A6 and now Bishop
to D3 attacking The Rook we have rooked
the A5 with check and now uh King to H6
King to H4 we have to kick away the
black king as far as possible uh before
we start pushing our Pawn so King to G6
Rook to G5 with checking the H6 and now
Rook to D5 attacking the bishop Bishop
C2 now Rook to D6 with check King to G7
and now King to G5 so uh this is this
this is the easy part the hard part is
actually getting the pawn uh all the way
to H7 so here Bishop to B1 uh Cinderella
can just wait and see what Prague will
do Rook D7 check King to G8 and now Rook
the C7 uh throwing the move uh to Black
getting the Rook away from a light
Square Bishop to D3 and now King the H6
with Bishop to F5 and now Rook to G7
with check and the King to f8 uh the
king can never cross the the h 7 Square
so Rook to G3 and now Bishop back to C2
so how are you getting this Pawn uh up
the board we have rooked G2 attacks the
bishop Bishop E4 and now Rook to G1 we
have King to F7 and Rook to G4 so as you
can see it's not that that simple Bishop
D3 Rook to G3 Bishop to C2 Rook the G2
and the bishop to D3 of course uh Joe
Walker would very much enjoy a
repetition of moves but Prague has to
play for the win of course as his
position is winning so Rook G7 came to
f8 and now Rook back to G3 attacks the
bishop Bishop to C2 and now uh Prague
cannot afford to keep attacking the
bishop as he might risk a three-fold
repetition so Pawn to H4 the pawn now
starts marching forward but still how
will it ever cross the H7 and H6 squares
so King to F7 rooked the C3 now going
after the bishop Bishop B1 and Rook to
F3 with check King to G8 with Rook to G3
checking F7 and now Rook the G7 with
check King f8 and now Rook back to G5
King to F7 and now you could easily make
a mistake here for example if you play
H5 here it's a draw there's no winning
this because now your one the white king
is completely boxed in you can't go to
the G6 you can't go to H7 and good luck
uh playing this for example Bishop D3
Rook to G3 attacks the bishop we're
gonna play Bishop back to B1 and if Rook
F3 even came to G8 again you are never
touching any of these squares you have
to go back with the king so here Prague
plays the winning move and it is uh very
very exemplary King to H5 now the King
has to go the other way around and then
the pawn can start marching forward you
do not want to trap your King on H6 so
here King to F6
uh King to G4 and the bishop to C2 and
now finally as our Rook is nicely
guarded on the G G file uh the king is
completely cut off from the G file it is
time to start to push the H pawn bishop
D1 checked but just King to F4 uh the
pawn is nicely protected Bishop C2 and
now Pawn to H6 this is how the pawn uh
starts marching forward and now we have
Bishop to G6 uh just uh preventing the
roof from coming to G7 the problem is if
you try repeating moves then Rook G7
ends the game on the spot because once
we make a move we're gonna move the Rook
somewhere well presumably on a dark
Square we're winning the H7 square and
that's it came to G6 H7 for example
that's a game over so after H6 Bishop
the G6 a nice attempt by uh cindarov
before the game actually ends but Prague
just plays Rook to G1 and it was in this
position on move 77 that pragananda won
the game or rather where Java Christina
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the problem is now
once you move the bishop Rook G7 as
you've seen is winning and if you try
playing King F7 then King E5 you take
away all the squares from the black king
so now the bishop cannot be defended and
the bishop has them once the bishop
moves it's Rook G7 check King fade Rook
C7 and now H7 will win the bishop
whatever you play we're just gonna push
H7 and now you have to give up the the
the bishop and win the game or even if
you don't
um uh try to play something like this if
you try something like King here then
you hang the bishop uh I mean there's
also that I know you guys forgot that
the bishop was saying uh so yeah after
Rook to G1 uh Cinderella resigns and a
brilliant brilliant victory for for
pragyananda that is not only uh
important for him but for a team India
too as well as currently the clash
between uh gookish and abusatrov is
being fought fiercely and now the result
of this game program under versus indoor
will have a great effect on the game
between gukash and W satrov as now
Abdullah cannot afford for for the game
to be a draw otherwise India will win
the match so uh could Anything could
happen in that game it is most
definitely the one I'm showing you after
this one so stay tuned for that it's
coming very very quickly so yeah once
again really hope you guys enjoyed this
one and once again sorry for the bad
audio quality in a few previous videos I
would like to thank natarjun rangasami
uh who boobies Joshua Hadley prasanna
krishnamurti and the Michael kalber for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon uh continuing the coverage of
the Olympiad until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day